assassin misses the six months after the
Panama papers cast a spotlight on the
vast extent of international tax evasion
and fraud the president of Panama is
visiting Germany he wants to drum up
investment but he also has the difficult
task of rebuilding trust president juan
carlos varela welcome to the interview
on DW which I say any Thank You Johnny
for the opportunity to show Germany and
the world the honest face of Panama
which is committed to financial
transparency and politics that serve the
people what i think of you dilemma and
welcome to you as well I am Jenny Pettis
in Berlin Berlin vasantha how
trustworthy is Panama six months after
the tax revelations both elemental
entirely trustworthy IM of the term
panama papers is inappropriate the
documents cast light on the global
problem of tax evasion panama has acted
responsibly and swiftly over the past
twenty eight months we've taken decisive
steps that affirmed our commitment to a
transparent financial system we're in
the forefront of international efforts
to protect financial systems but mr.
president panama is on France's
blacklist and has had to enhance
financial transparency because it was
given an ultimatum by the OECD and the
g20 is Panama still dangerous territory
for the international financial order
it's been often i say my ultimate the
blacklist is a domestic matter for
france where taxes important issue in
the upcoming elections but japan germany
in the united states have acknowledged
that panama has been proactive in
addressing the problems and passed laws
to protect the financial system in the
interest of the common good so we are
optimistic do hope to meet death row
xanthus wanted mr. president according
to transparency international's
Corruption Perceptions Index Panama
ranks lower than Rwanda and Cuba
including its judicial system what do
you say to that it's simply wrong our
country has changed of course we have to
deal with our past even if we're not
directly responsible for it but over the
past twenty eight months we've done a
lot
accountability and the separation of
powers for the first time state
institutions are working properly there
is accountability the country is making
progress because it guarantees its
institutions respect the law degree
including the press a couple of days ago
the inter-american Press Association
called on your government to end its
campaign to week in critical media that
have reported on the Panama papers and
as it put it the declining popularity of
the president is that how your
government sees transparency SI leader
transparency no Suh gobierno y la cita
Kyoko the association was wrong and
acted impulsively it made these
assertions at the end of its conference
so the government could not present its
case and nobody's questioning the media
in general just a few things certain
individuals did at time when they were
in charge of state-owned banks it has
nothing to do with press freedom which
kind of our respects just read our
newspapers momento que si hace NATO a
formal hubiera censored paper of the
pasa group no papers are censored
certain individuals in the media face
questions about certain infractions of
the law so there's no intimidation SI
para la cosa you have to distinguish
between various issues that have nothing
to do with each other we're talking
about misappropriation of state funds at
the state bank the relevant authorities
are investigating the cases mr.
president a month ago you told Bloomberg
that the Panama papers are a media
matter are you saying the media created
the problem i will make tax evasion is a
global issue if you mean the problem but
say panama papers that is a media
artifact the panama papers is what the
media talk about but tax fraud is global
in a mophie colombo dimelo the OECD says
panama should adopt the measures it has
proposed to enhance transparency have
you made as much progress as other
countries no keep an eye on problemas
panama panama has been following this
path since 2009 when i was foreign
minister Motoko sali del gobierno
and I had to leave the government slowed
things down but when the people elected
me as their president the temple picked
up and we've done everything we were
asked to do between 2011 in 2013 the
country was indeed not doing the right
thing but I accept my responsibilities
and have the support of Parliament which
swiftly passed a series of laws
empezamos a una forma que pasa con las
you say you were doing everything that
has to be done but the US economist and
Nobel laureate Joseph Stiglitz has said
the Panamanian government is not
committed to transparency what do you
say to that I said he thought he had
been invited to join a commission
investigating our financial system and
the Panamanians on the Commission failed
to agree in the criteria but those
members are by no means close to the
government they're independent
experienced and very professional
nonetheless there were differences of
opinion and mr. Stieglitz decided to
leave the commission's report will be
published for me if I said public it
wasn't only Stiglitz who resigned but
also the Swiss anti-corruption expert
mark Pete they both said the government
did not want to know the whole truth why
won't you allow the report to be
published in its entirety alien form is
a Republican report I will be published
the participation of outside experts was
important to us but differences emerged
in the two decided to resign but they're
still welcome to take part and look at
the findings cuando quiera a participar
iya iya resultados de and also the
Panamanian press say you have close ties
to individuals under investigation
including the lawyer ramon fonseca what
are your connections to him in our
political ties are currently under
investigation he was vice president of
our political party and he's a friend of
mine he has to answer the accusations
for which he's being investigated how
was it for you when the scandal broke
anything yes I offended my first thought
was what does it mean for my country
ninety nine point eight percent of the
economy has nothing to do with legal
services unlike tax havens which depend
on hosting offshore companies got it
our economy depends on the fruit of our
labor the canal the airport's tourism
and a large service sector it has to do
with our location and is the work of the
Panamanian people so we're not worried
the problem concerns point2 percent of
the economy and we took corrective
measures at once no me hace que miata
mente say tomorrow correct Evo's how
much did you know before the scandal
broke and hit the headlines medicine
have been sent that message just so he
can get oh I'm an engineer a numbers man
economic growth is six percent
unemployment is three and a half percent
inflation is less than one percent uno
por ciento and the shell companies
that's a matter for the lawyers how it
all cases are under investigation
including ones that date from my time is
foreign minister yet though catechols i
started my term as president by signing
tax treaties and treaties on sharing tax
information at the foreign ministry I
learned a lot Baima we're all the
progress panama has made regarding
financial transparency has happened on
my watch starting in two thousand nine
when I became foreign minister and since
2014 is present well not that the
financial system lacked any transparency
its robust and we have tough loss oh the
new international rules are key they
said the norms countries have to accept
but did you know about the financial
system before the scandal broke it'll
allow a rectangle of co no no no teeny
ago cimento i had no direct knowledge of
it there are hundreds of thousands of
companies in Panama and now we know who
owns what how the system was exploited
how would I think we're done talking for
the important thing is we have passed
the relevant laws let me not abolished
bearer shares hey Melissa we now require
companies to identify their owners shell
companies are not specific to Panama
there an issue in the United States the
Caribbean luxembourg Switzerland and
many other countries yes we sold mi on
mi mucho France in 2011 and the IMF both
called on Panama to enhance transparency
so here in Europe we've been wondering
how it's possible that there have been
serious problems with the legal system
we've acknowledged that
and acted fast to make changes extensive
measures are required given the
international norms and the need to
ensure the criminal organizations cannot
exploit the financial system but I
cannot do it alone parliament has to
pass legislation the country's social
and economic players need to reach a
consensus one thing is clear it's the
people who suffer the most will you
share information on financial and bank
transactions with Germany and other
countries automatic oh yeah that happens
automatically we've signed more than 20
treaties the first was with Japan I met
Prime Minister hobby we've written to
all the countries we have tax treaties
with to bring the treaties in line with
the OECD guidelines on sharing
information the relevant clauses are
already in our new treatments and they
will soon be added to our treaty with
Germany coupon includes a cloud sula
elderly man yellow a good muy pronto can
be no greater so is the tax scandal
having an impact on your most
high-profile project expanding the canal
traffic and revenues have been declining
for six months now that is since the
scandal broke that has to do with the
global economy the expansion has been
completed about 180 ships have already
passed through the canal we expecting
come next year to rise by six hundred
million dollars we invest in projects to
benefit the people of Panama it's not a
Panamanian scandal but a global scandal
right but it happened in Panama the
connection to Panama is the fictional
part of the story added by journalists
it's unfair to us Panamanians still we
faced up to the challenge estamos
viviendo Tokaido guess panama soon of
course panama is a whole country hi guys
and more suck Fonseca just a law firm
boyer the question is how did it get to
be so powerful everyone well firms like
that are everywhere in total there are
11 and a half million documents were
leaked the entire global political order
has been implicated in it hmm see but
what yes but not all shell firms are
based in panama that's why i say it's a
global problem
LOL what s encontro you met with chance
remark what do you expect from Germany
in this new period for Panama hey money
that won't move up a leader germany
plays a leading role in the European
Union and Panama wants to play the
equivalent role in Central America and
the Caribbean say what yet we want
closer ties with Germany in areas such
as education security the war on
terrorism governance strengthening
democratic institutions and social
justice boy he who no political our aim
is to pursue a kind of politics that
benefits all the people of the planet
donita so important we have been
following this miracle closely I like I
said American people she's a strong and
humane leader and what's more the German
economy is strong and many German firms
are involved in projects in Panama
German technology is everywhere in the
new subway and in the canal for example
that I'm you chatting little he le monde
involucre mr. president thank you very
much